we will now begin Our Moment of Silence
to pay our respects to John
Lennon lenen was walking in and this kid
says John
lenen John was laying straight out like
that no movement nothing this guy just
shot John Lon the alleged killer isk
David chap Chapman is a photographer
from
Hawaii and why have you never spoken
about I just didn't want any trouble but
time's passed
he actually apologized to us he said GE
I'm sorry I ruined your night and I said
you got to be kidding me you just ruined
your whole life was somebody working
with him was it a conspiracy his
intention was to bring Fame to himself
was religion a motive and he said my
name is Mark David Chapman you'll
remember my name nobody's ever given
peace a complete chance Gandhi tried it
Martin Luther King tried it but they
were
shocked